I said in a courtroom before and most
cases are not like would you argue
mothers that that's not your hard drive
it wasn't wasn't a child pornography
case I was not the defendant I observed
a courtroom Oh for what
when I was a young man I was on youth
court what is that it's a gym was that
when we talked about [ __ ] yep Jim's
never heard this what is Youth Court
well Esther I'll tell you yeah what is
it I wanna be judge guess who's got no
underpants under his robe I'd like to be
tried by the youth core yeah
hey Jay courts in session everyone slide
down them trousers when I look for the
evidence of my fingers so you know when
I was a young man in Westchester it
started and this is a very impressive
thing most people don't start youth
court until they're in ninth grade I got
in when I was in eighth grade and it's
this smarty pants I know it's this thing
it's not school sanctioned it's a
government thing so you go outside of
school hours like in the evening right
and and and they you do an interview and
stuff and they bring you on board and
then they teach you they spend like
probably almost a year teaching you
about the law and then it was an
after-school program yeah but it was
like a night so it wasn't right after
school mm-hmm but it was you know is it
but it was like a government sanctioned
program and then once you've gone
through that you get to start trying
real cases like they bring in
misdemeanor cases that would normally go
to Family Court of adults no kids yeah
so like kids who do graffiti kids you
shoot BB guns stuff like that and they
don't you shoot their parents no not
quite that severe kids are some other
they're infants the attention their
bunny rabbits on fire not much but it's
stuff that like they would go and say if
you want to go to Family Court you can
and that's a regular court system but if
you go to youth
the most you'll get is community service
hours and when you're 18 it gets
expunged from your record sure and so
that's the that's why people choose to
do it and we would switch roles every
week you know they get handed out and it
would be two kids would be the the
defending attorneys to say you played an
attorney
two kids would be the prosecuting
attorneys one kid would be the bailiff
and two kids would be the judge what and
it was like a real courtroom how are you
eighth grade I started in eighth grade
so I started actually going through
cases once I was in nineteen you ever
run into these kids like outside of the
courtroom well yeah and it was got you
first of all you're supposed to take
yourself off a case if somebody that you
knew was on it you're supposed to go to
the detective stayed no dorky but I know
what a bunch of [ __ ] little creeps
and you'd have to wear like a suit court
were you also a hall monitor no I know
but I go and like my buddy was on trial
cuz either would you say oh boy
I'm screwed no it wasn't that instance
but he did like a ton of graffiti and he
was right on trial for having douchebag
friends no but he walked in and like as
he was walking you know down the aisle
to get to the front of the courtroom if
you weren't on the case you did have to
observe the case and I like Wix I didn't
you can't play the sound bite of me
saying it as I'm talking that what you
would say when you got him no I like
dicks I wouldn't say that she was a
defense no how do you plead you gotta
stop throwing so I would go and and and
he came up and like as he was walking
you know up the aisle towards the court
he was like oh hey what's up Sam and all
like the people in the Youth Court gave
me like dirty looks because I knew one
of the bad kids it's embarrassing should
be it was embarrassing or maybe give you
some street cred I think it but not what
the youth court kids they were like they
didn't they were like oh you hang out
with with the ruffians you know
rough-and-tumble friends the
rough-and-tumble 's did any of them
become lawyers
no I didn't keep up with I won best
lawyer in my class you weren't a lawyer
your clients I was a social studies mr.
Anderson we did we did do mr. Anderson
we did do lower classes I mean I like
legal stuff sounds very official yeah
yeah I was a good lawyer you weren't in
real cases well just in class I was in
real transpossession stuff like that
let's face she's made it up no no we did
actually do drug possession MA and I
remember how I got I lost with one case
I lost I pled wrong you only lost one
case I pleaded incorrectly how's that
because the drugs were found in the
locker mm-hmm and I pleaded guilty to
possession but then I made a good
argument about how it shouldn't have
been possession because that's a public
thing the school locker and other people
do have access to it and I made a really
good argument but then they reminded me
that I pled guilty to my oh yeah I said
he we did do it I gave him that was a
mistake however I did catch my friend
Joe free no lying about like you did one
case about how far it was to go to work
and I'm like how far of a drive is it
for you and he goes about eight hours
eight hours each way so you drive 16
hour trial this is real life even though
things yeah I hated it though because I
realized that there was other work
involved like when you were an attorney
when you were a defending attorney you
actually had to call the families of
these [ __ ] little miscreant kids to
like work out hey how are we gonna
defend this thing like you had to
interview the parents and interview the
why these cry these kids crying like in
the courthouse no because it was all
[ __ ] trials it was all just like the
most thing you could do was a whole
bunch of hours of community service and
the least thing you could do was a few
hours of community like so they were
already out of trouble totally it was an
only community service we could hand out
and it was going to get expunged from
writing his mother's throat would they
let him go - hey like weird crime ly
antisocial crimes like what like we like
he's 11 and we brought home a little
sibling and
he's been [ __ ] in the baby bottle
[Laughter]
struggled with that case I never added
the thank God never had to try that well
no no so it was all stuff like vandalism
vandalism shooting BB guns I think
somebody lit like a building on fire
Jesus yeah
Son of Sam [ __ ] he shot two people
making love yeah he was a Firebug was
this before you turn to a life of crime
impersonating wrestlers online and I was
doing it at the same time oh my god it's
crazy yeah I was like a little Nico yes
my lawyer my criminal it's a great book
[Laughter]
there was what I told you guys Sam come
here
thank you Jim the most like the worst
part of the whole thing my whole
experience I'll never ever forget it was
I got to be the judge younger than most
people because I started younger than
most people and when you're the judge so
you're used to be hating everybody
hating you yeah everybody new to him
everybody hated me but when you're the
judge like you get these you know you
get you have your manuals and it says in
the manual exactly what the judge is
supposed to say right I didn't do any
homework Oh before this thing she just
made stuff up no so I stood up I sat up
on the stand you know with my book did
you wear a robe yeah it was the judge of
course I wore a rose black dress his
mother gave him it's a cocktail gown
frock she brought it home which is why
they're [ __ ] stains in the front but it's
in there and I am I manual because I had
to read what the judge was supposed to
say to the clients looking at like the
my peers who were the attorneys and the
people who were there but I didn't know
what page it was in the book so I just
sat there on the stand with everybody
looking at me we're panicking what oh my
god was I panicking I was flipping
through the pages it was nowhere to be
found it felt like I was up there for an
hour but I'm sure it was just like
minutes and one of the lawyers had to
walk up from the stand and approach the
bench one of the cade lawyers kid
lawyers and just move more like any
adults in this courthouse it was ever
like a couple detectives the runs five
guys in the back just jacking off
she had to walk up and move my book to
the right page and then walk back and
just tell me just read that that's fine
you're straight judge exactly its person
how long were you a judge for a day for
that's right Wow that trial and then I
probably was a judge a couple more times
after that
oh yeah that's right Esther one of the
more times after that day a good judge
no I
that first one I was read first one
really really were you were you leaving
are you leaning on these kids mm-hmm no
okay did you get like a Puck's attorney
Phil here you hitting the gavel down
were you ever worried these kids would
like shoot their BB gun at you like on
the playground no because first of all
ran into you outside of the corner
that's a good question where they take
your marbles we're in high school we're
not playing marbles is that what you do
in high school yeah that's what we did
play marbles on you playing jacks in
high school that's true oh yeah there's
what I mean there's these things you
pick up right yeah no no we just trade
jacks were you good at jacks
I never played jacks didn't you have to
like go like pick up one than 20 season
Tuesday's and threesies I never played
jacks you know what happened I wasn't
born in the 1950s I wish you weren't in
the eighties either I don't know I play
Jackson as a kid they made video games
for us
so that's track did you play jacks when
you're a kid um no she didn't play jacks
she's a very well-rounded person I
played Zoo what is Zoo
you get a bowl of grapefruit a great
night cereal and everybody goes on the
floor and starts eating Grape Nuts Syria
and you pick an animal that you're gonna
play and the whole house turns into a
zoo well you gotta use Grape Nuts
it looks like animal food oh yeah stupid
I played the same thing but with
shredded wheat thins did you frosted
mini-wheats
no they weren't frosted before they
certainly weren't rusted Underpants so
you are you would do the animals then
but then what was the point of the game
great dance to just act like an animal
or also also to pick like an animal that
you look like you know like if I think
you look like a rhino
I'll be like you're the Rhino like
everybody assigned each other you'll
assign you giraffe that sucks
why is your f cuz I have a long neck she
does have a long neck
yeah that's traumatized you feel like
I'm talking to the toys-r-us I know how
many other famous to outs are there
[Laughter]
Jeffery comment this is where we played
one game call the screaming to the
pillow I sure do put your face in the
pillow and when it hurts too bad you
scream and then someone else jackpot we
played it differently okay good you had
to do all these tasks right like grab an
orange or like all these things like
it's almost like a treasure hunt sure
and then at the end after all these
tasks that you had to do you had to
touch our mom's butt and whoever did
that whose idea was it your mom and dad
watches hand them all a knife to mothers
button and then whoever you know
finished all the tennis and then
finished on my mom's butt would win we'd
all scream jackpot what's a weird thing
to do that's a really weird game is it
weird yeah yeah
does your mom yeah remember that you
guys used to play touch her but I mean
like she wanted us to touch her because
you want to play jackpot well like we
would all wash away yeah at the end you
come over and you you talked a little
fleshy that's why when kids came over
and played with us for one day they
never came back wait no you to win you
come over you're tugged a fleshie treat
bag you tug on a fleshy treat bag
you win some treats I know yeah I got a
win some milk wrist doesn't always have
to be so like you know sure it does to
feel good
that one was my fault I walk in joy yep
I need you know it sounds so weird now
does it
no undie flip is probably worse that's
creepin do or touch my mom on the butt
cheek yeah unda flip is awful called
jackpot Sam oh I'm sorry
you know the game on D flip what is that
Travis used to play it by the way it's
way worse than [ __ ] youth chord okay
so when I was in high school I was
making sure that the the laws of
Westchester were upheld so what would
you explain to her what uh first of all
you can't start playing until you have
pubes not a rule yeah that's the way
I've always heard it my brother and I'd
we used to get naked and put our
underwear on our like ankle slash foot
and we try to flip it up to the ceiling
fan are you on your back no standing you
stand if I'm trying to flip panties up
in the air yeah but they have to be they
have to be joined together a Lebel would
you guys cheat like if you were like no
that's not on your ankle you got your
underpants on your toes you can't do
that yeah you had to do it right Sam
there's rules right living a lawless
Society who would normally undo flip
whoever came first 51 so you're the perv
I mean we're less than one day Travis we
they knew the game was over when one day
Travis was a little older and he wanted
to incorporate a Ritz cracker into the
head when you put your underwear back on
you probably put on your brothers
underwear well no we would leave it up
there and then my mom would get upset
when she would turn the ceiling fan on
and the underwear would fly off with
absolutely to duty and semen fill
objects in the air your mom would get
upset because she'd find underwear on
the ceiling fan and then eventually
would leave with a Jewish man no what
happened was the underwear flew off flew
off and landed on his father's head and
she went I like that one
Travis's mom abruptly left his family
for a man a rabbi sent oh yeah one day
and she's never spoken to them saying
yeah and she made Travis missed the last
episode of Monday nitro oh I'm sorry to
hear that it's fine
I'm over it until Sam brings it up it's
on the network have you ever seen Travis
I've seen parts of it it's a trigger for
Travis he can't watch it yeah it just
starts crying and speaking Yiddish did
you play any weird little sex games when
you're younger yeah I'm good yeah we
play them too
what'd you play we played this thing we
didn't have a name for it but like you
just go under my parents blanket and you
take off all your clothes and one kid
takes you with your parents in the room
no they weren't there and then one kid
takes the clothes and runs out of the
room the whoever is underneath the
blanket is naked by the way somebody
just posted a photo of Judge Sam and and
then everybody screams and delight
because it's like you know but then
you're all naked no but then you bring
the clothes back and then you put the
clothes back on so you just have one kid
running around naked with all your no no
you're not running around you're in the
bed naked oh you know I mean the kid
that took the clothes they come back is
he naked no they they're not naked oh so
they're the odd man out or odd it seems
you're just naked yeah whoever is under
the blanket is naked but it's like
exciting cuz it's like somebody's naked
but you didn't say Jim used to suck his
friend's dick yeah and one time you've
used in this mouth twice I did for me
for me twice shame on me
boy it's like I don't remember and I
might have that's worse than the bed
game isn't it yeah yeah drink piss in
the pool well what would you have done
if Jim's friend came into youth court
and and said that you know Jim came and
said if you urinated in my mouth and he
said he would or he peed in my mouth now
is that what he's on trial for is Jim
just there's a character
this no that's what he's on trial for
lying against this man he told me he
would not pee in my mouth exactly he did
once ago what would the punishment be
for that I would definitely old was he
I we're both like fire second third
grade we probably yeah we normally
wouldn't get kids in that young but I
would I would probably try to throw the
book at him that means I mean I would
probably he would end up with up to 20
hours of community service that's it we
are mean we couldn't we couldn't go that
far with the punishments yeah 20 hours I
think 20 hours was about as far as we
mean it depends if he's if he's lying to
Jim about pissing in his mouth multiple
times maybe I could give him 20 hours
for each time I had to do community
service I got I got arrested for
something I didn't do it what you get
arrested for just being with people who
are getting high those drugs or
something that's a bit like minor
possession oh yeah I mean they were
smoking pot I mean you know it's just a
being remember what the actual charge
was no it's it was so minor I just got
some community sir you know did your
parents get pissed yeah I think an old
person's home I had to go to that's why
I know how old people smell when they're
dying
yeah not them but just keep the place
clean it was a New Brunswick is not bad
yeah but I member this one all fat old
lady would walk by and you could
literally smell her five minutes later
it smelled like rot it was I never knew
that that smell existed that a person
could smell like that she was dying you
think she was just a holdover AZ yeah
and I remember that I think the guy's
name was Paul who worked there I don't
remember the other two guys they were
like or yeah they were I was like 13 or
12 whatever 14 died I was younger than
13 and they were 25 year old guys that
you know was a weird place did they ever
try to touch you no they were creepy
they did you ever try to touch them no
it was just yeah go go do this mop here
that's [ __ ] did you get into sexual
stuff when you were in like high school
cuz I I feel like all your weird sexual
stories come when you're like young yeah
yeah no I did what you do in high school
same stuff I remember it's this one girl
in your mouth no no no but this one girl
I told you this sister but the girl my
balls were really sweaty so I was drunk
and my was the middle of summer I was
wearing army pants
to try to get my balls dry cuz she was
gonna blow me I put baby powder on them
yeah and I wasn't supposed to do that
before right yeah yeah not once it was
really sweaty right saw she was blowing
me and I smelled bad and I remember she
was like she stopped is disgusting are
you wearing army pants in the summer
that's those cool was it nope the leash
are getting blown though yeah I mean
some kids don't get blown I wasn't
getting blown much yeah mine did what's
a dirty boy good for you
surprised you weren't you didn't take
advantage of your judge power I should
have known oh yeah oh there are girls
who were volunteers too
yeah but they were all like there was a
girl that showed me the right page in
the book it's humiliating
you know what did she like said maybe
she's dominant she might love that yeah
but they probably looked at me like this
kid is not fit to be a judge so what
none of you guys were fit to do anything
I mean I enjoin sight that's a great
point yeah what do you think she was a
real prosecutor did that you don't know
hang them killers no I have no idea I
haven't kept in contact with any of them
okay no none of them I'm sure some of
them became alcoholics do you miss them
no were you popular in high school my
friend yeah I mean that wasn't unpopular
but I wasn't like the cool kid I just do
you know I just floated between clicks
oh yeah friends I didn't have enemies
people didn't well some people hated me
I'm sure but I wasn't widely hated I
wasn't beaten up or anything like that I
wasn't a weirdo okay just a goofball be
popular in high school no no people
hated me why I get that no one time I
went in the bathroom in my high school
and it said on the wall somebody wrote
Esther ku go to hell die
what yes pretty to think of a good rhyme
with ku I just liked that you were so
like well-known that somebody just out
of the blue just wrote that on the wall
what are the [ __ ] blue yeah why were
you so hated that somebody would just go
to the bathroom and be like you know
what [ __ ] Esther ku gonna hell and die
go to hell and die um I don't know maybe
because of stuff I wrote in the school
paper
would you write in the school paper like
expose sand
administration and the teachers why
would kids hate that I would be popular
I feel like it was a teacher Esther ku
Catala died probably school paper
well I would take like quotes that the
teacher said and print them in the paper
like what kind of quotes like um you
know like that sweater Esther was jester
who would die like you know funny things
that teacher said or like perverted
inappropriate things that they said that
like what - like - like students like
that our gym teacher said to to a
classmate of mine you why is your left
boob bigger than your right boob and I
printed in the newspaper and then he got
in trouble at the dean's office what's
amazing is you answer though why was the
one tick bigger if you'd publish that
today that high school newspaper article
would probably become like a national
story to be everywhere yeah yeah did he
go right on the curve no he didn't get
fired but maybe like a dork yeah I wrote
on the school paper so I would get
people in trouble yeah from what I wrote
and then the teachers would be called
into the dean's office and they were
like is this is this true what you said
and your byline was right there every
knew who wrote it
Yeah right after the snitch I wrote for
the I wrote for the school newspaper a
little bit no but all the Advocate no
that's a game but my I I've only had a
couple articles printed because I would
just keep going in and pitching
wrestling ideas no we're not doing that
oh I know why in my head it made sense
like of course this completely relates I
should write about like what the [ __ ]
NWO is doing and they go no when I we're
not putting it in the school newspaper
it doesn't usually make any sense you
started a wrestling journal or blog
bright the way they have blogs back then
but you just assume that everybody was
into wrestling assume everybody's into
wrestling you like wrestling right um I
mean I don't really watch wrestling what
I don't either
what yeah it's weird why I thought I did
know
yeah suit yourself you guys didn't like
stay up late and watch the Japanese
wrestling pay-per-view in the middle of
the night last night you know about when
I woke up this morning and caught the
end how was it [ __ ] awesome alpha
versus Omega my god so why they hate you
because um because I wrote I talked [ __ ]
about the Rosemont kids like the
Rosemont kids went to our high school
and they were the rich kids and
everybody else was like working-class
but those kids who grew up in Rosemont
they had a gated community
so the sotius didn't like you yeah and
there Elaine wrote something their
parents hated me because they had like
like the town of Rosemont is where
O'Hare Airport is right and they don't
have to pay taxes because the airport
brings in so much money Wow yeah so so
there's like a very small residential
area of Rosemont where you know there's
like a handful of houses and they just
are more well-off than the rest of us
and they have to deal with the airport
noise and the traffic that's probably
part of it too is that the congestion
it's like you're dealing with a night
it's a pain in the ass to have an
airport your neighborhood but I don't
pay local taxes this houses must be so
expensive it's yeah but those those kids
were more well-off than everybody else
we're well-to-do yes and then but then
they went to our high school right and
so there's the rich kids that we're
writing that you should go to hell in
the bathroom probably right so I wrote
in the school paper you know you're from
Rosemont when you pay your way to the
top and I put parentheses valedictorian
and homecoming queen because they were
both from Rosemont my senior year so you
accused the valedictorian and the
homecoming queen of bribery I mean it
was always like a funny column that I
wrote and it was just meant to be a joke
but then the town of Rosemont went crazy
on me and like these parents they like
Xerox copy day and put in everybody's
door in the town of Rosemont and then
they wanted me they wanted my column to
be censored from the paper and was it
they had meetings about about like what
we should do what a troublemaker what
did you get censored or no I did yeah so
my column they didn't let my call and be
printed in the newspaper the next week
were you mad um did you feel like your
journalistic barter
I wanted to study journalism and and I
was mad so I went and started and this
is one like everybody just started
getting hot mail addresses AOL so I
started an underground newspaper and I
would email like my friends like what I
would have printed in the paper without
you know having my journalism teacher
approve of things so I just wrote what I
wanted to write and then it kind of went
like viral in my high school like
everybody kind of printed it out and was
passing around at school that's cool
yeah so but then as your parents think
of your journalistic pursuits they
didn't really oh you know what my mom
called the school because they took away
like this Citizenship Award that I got
why because a good citizen because I
started this underground newspaper and
the principal called me into the office
and he had printed out I had a column
called you know you have your period
when you you know sound like a diaper
when you're walking down the hallway and
stuff so so the teacher the principal
had this printed out and he was like he
was like what is all this I'm like what
it's just my paper and I didn't
distribute it on the school yeah other
people are but I didn't sure so like I
didn't get suspended or expelled which I
kind of wish I did because maybe I would
have made the Tribune or something oh
yeah girl gets expelled for writing
about periods yeah yeah I could see that
as a headline but instead they kept me
in school because I was like an honor
roll student and then right and they
just took away my River Grove mayor's
award for good citizenship and my mom
called the principal and was like please
get to award back to my daughter now I
don't care about the award I give a [ __ ]
I'm like it's better that it got revoked
I'm like I'm more proud of that right
you're the badass they never got it back
that's you're a rebel yes so so this kid
Sean Maher he hated me maybe he went
into women's restroom and wrote that
maybe was when when I got the award he
was like why did you get it I'm like I
don't know like the principal just
doesn't know how I act in class he just
assumed like sure your wisenheimer band
what is that why is this again how would
he have got into the girls room to write
it yeah I spy a girl who wrote a boys
not going to the girls school probably
one of the females OSHA's who wrote it
by the airport I probably probably
girl that I made a fat joke about don't
say her last name what you say about you
know a lot of people that hated you yeah
what do you say back there's a lot of
suspects no but she wasn't fat I just
made I was actually just making a joke
that she was um yeah but she was feeding
but like you know how girls think that
they're fat sure so she just took it
personally so you gave a skinny girl
with complex yeah right okay yeah no
body shame he never hurt I guess because
I was probably skinnier than her so you
were bragging about it no I wasn't I
didn't mean to I was just joking around
what'd you say that was it for
good-natured or was it mean I forgot
what I said but call me a fat pig no but
another when I was in eighth grade I
learned what the word obese men uh-huh
that's great word did you use that one I
did I'm like I'm just looking at the
technical definition of obese and I I
called Sarah obese and then Sarah hated
me calling her obese right was she a
fatty no she was just big-boned
she wasn't obese but I was just trying
to like use a new word which is probably
fast I was a dork I was just like you
know you love the word right to increase
my vocabulary but when you're not obese
but you are big yeah you're sensitive
about that general you said when
somebody gives you definitely don't want
to be segwayed into obese because you're
sitting there going like well maybe
maybe I'm not as fat as I think I'm
big-boned right I'm a tall girl people
probably don't see me the way I see me I
see fat but maybe they don't see me as
fat 100 pound Esther says you're obese
what you say well one time I was peeing
and she and her friend came over and
they took a picture of me peeing yeah
while I was on the toilet
mhm and they get fired for their
satellite radio job no the teacher I do
it the photo well I know what I'd do
with it I told the teacher I go I go
Sara just took a picture of me peeing in
the bathroom and she mates with a snitch
we were a rat well don't you put that in
your paper scoops yeah she goes delete
that picture but she didn't really make
them delete the picture right she's told
cuz they were more popular they still
have it
yeah I saw it do you think they still
have it probably do they do anything
with it no I looked at the photo you
couldn't really see anything it was like
an aerial shot right was from over the
stall yeah and it was on like a
disposable like 35 millimeter all was
that's right no cell phone you know
printed at Walgreens why would your
teachers say delete that photo on a
disposable camera
well like open up the camera I'm not
ruining my camera she's like no yeah
roll film here and what could I do
right okay yeah no it's ruined it's gone
now they take to develop film like I've
never done I have I'm about three to
five days oh really
well now you can get it but I mean in
your own place I have a really dark
closet I could probably do film
developing in there I don't have any
film them just curious you should do it
just a couple minutes yeah yeah that
fast yeah you gotta take the you never
did it in school yeah it was never a
hobby for me just dip the chemicals and
then put them up to dry and stuff oh
that's right theatre hang on I'm gonna
put a dark room in your house no I'm not
I was just thinking like my closet so
pitch-black that you could develop
photos yeah I mean it's something I
guess I wouldn't have I wouldn't it
wouldn't have occurred to me what was
the movie where they developed all those
I'll blow out with John Travolta and
Nancy Allen where they witness and act
there's an accident or something and
through a bunch of photos they make them
like a little film because they make the
pictures go fat it's so it's such a
stretch do you remember that movie no I
never try now ever see one hour photo
yeah baby that's pretty good movie you
find out at the end that like this one
family's been coming in there for years
and every single time they come in he's
just making copies of their photos for
himself yeah it was creepy yeah it was
really creepy was very creepy in that
movie sy the photo guy yeah that was
cool this this movie I forget exactly
what happened with Ronnie yeah but it
was definitely the way they took all of
the photos and made them move fast like
a movie but it was not enough photos and
yes but they still made it look like
really like a movie and say it doesn't
work that way
there wasn't nearly enough no no that's
too bad that's too bad
when there's just obvious plot holes
they're like what do you do this isn't a
movie yeah I can snake and go faster